and I look like an emo goth sitting next
to you some vampire got to me in the
middle of the night which is great
[Music]
Louise here today to praise you guys
Louie how do you feel about it that's
good that's like I love doing that yeah
it's perfect do you feel like you're
gonna do a good job yeah I'm gonna take
a joke
okay well someone's modest okay yeah
definite 4 1 3 1 9 person to person to
person probably I don't know what a new
person comments on any of my social
media welcome to the family yeah but
today Louie you're gonna give it so
Steph Explorer one three one 900 there's
numbers mm-hmm
more like that is up to tricks that's
great oh my god I like your face you
can't have it it's mine but thanks I
like your face you can't have it it's
mine oh this is from Sally cinnamon
person to person to person boom is that
you're crazy
spent the whole of my son day off work
binge watching your YouTube and also
managed to fit he came to Kota Bluebird
whoo oh yes come to Kota is doing it to
watch that okay this is from Elinor
skater new person to person to person oh
oh I'm getting a phone call my bad
ignore and then enough skates are more
like Ellen greater than everyone else in
the world except for at breakfast it's
well she's crazy
great great I totally ship my three
favorite youtubers Troye Sivan Tyler
Oakley grace Helbig to make Trey slur oh
my god I can't cope this has to be a
thing how would that work that would be
like they do a thing and then I name is
above stars and streetlights new person
to person to person above the stars and
street lights like above Mars and tree I
don't think you do it work tree tree
types you're great
the Hammacher and they can't wait to
meet them at VidCon what are your
expectations for VidCon this year lots
of people I think it's gonna be me a lot
of different scents yeah lots of hugs
lots of hugs do you like the house
you know they happen oh my smell big new
first a new person new person
oh my smell big more like you know big
and have some big smells going on too in
a nice way like flowery floral smells
that has been covered in dog [ __ ] this
might get weird y'all grace Helbig what
were you thinking of if you had to
caption what you think I was thinking of
you was thinking about some kind of fate
oh yeah
do you think you know proud of but no
the first a new person to person
no more like half more father died yeah
always have more fun no you play hmm
grace hit her head
anything recently or fell the stairs
again there's a mark in the upper left
side yeah I have a scar here can they
fell down stairs so they guessed it yeah
but that happened like months and months
and months maybe even a year ago but
you've got someone nice and concerned
yeah I guess it just means that the scar
is more obvious I cut bangs over it
before
that's why how did you go downstairs I
was playing with a doll on my neighbor's
deck after a real night of socializing
and yeah and the my balance got away
from me
Mercedes not been you person to person
to person missing he's not Ben's more
like crazy
what a beautiful idiot oh that's nice
yeah favorite I should make sure it says
say that what were you yes good that's a
good line I feel like we're all
beautiful ideas Louie you did it he
prays like this every time praising have
a good day all right yeah you did a
great job I don't like to put numbers on
things
numbers are you know anyway we might not
a tie-dye how you doing
yeah I know and I thought the only tie I
like this food so let's go get some okay
go and check out his video I don't know
how do you get so tan Jesus look at
these little weirdos yeah nailing it
boop boop
squishing your heads squishing your head